Das Langzeit-EKG ist eine spezielle Form des sogenannten EKG, bei der wir die Ströme
ihres Herzens für längere Zeit messen, zum Beispiel ein bis zwei Tage.
Sie bekommen hierfür ein Gerät mit nach Hause.
Das Gerät ist klein und hat eine Batterie und kann zum Beispiel am Gürtel befestigt
werden.
Außerdem bekommen sie einen Brustgurt, den sie bitte möglichst die ganze Zeit auch
nachts beim Schlafen tragen sollten.
Mit dieser Methode können wir auch Störungen am Herzen erkennen, die nicht dauerhaft sind,
die also nur hin und wieder auftreten.
Es kann wichtig sein, solche Störungen zu erkennen und gegebenenfalls zu behandeln.